un second débat d'actualité
les chiffres vertigineux de la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église sont un
électrochoc pour toute la société
française que l'on soit ou non croyants
cécile 6 où vous
devez
payer
pour
tous ses crimes
face caméra
françois devaux de mâche pas ses mots
envers l'église figurent des victimes de
violences sexuelles de la part de
religieux il a salué le travail de la
commission sauvé c'est de l'enfer dont
vous revenez vous ment la commission
d'apporter enfin aux victimes une
reconnaissance institutionnelle
de toute la responsabilité de l'église
au terme de trois ans d'enquêté et de
centaines d'auditions la commission
dévoile des chiffres terrifiants 330 mi
mineur aurait été agressée entre 1950 et
2020 par des personnels de l'église un
choc pour le président de la conférence
des évêques de france eric moulins
beaufort ce qui est mis à jour est
effrayant et doit être mis vraiment à
jour jusqu'au bout et donc les pardons
que je demande je demande où tous les
tours nous avons encore à travailler
pour pouvoir de demander ce pardon non
pas simplement quelques personnes qui
sont là et que je connais mais à
l'immensité du nombre de celles et de
ceux qui ont été évoqués jean-marc sauvé
a présenté 45 recommandations parmi
lesquelles un contrôle des casiers
judiciaires des prêtres ou encore
l'éloignement systématique des
agresseurs mais surtout la remise à plat
des procédures de justice interne à
l'église il faut que les mise catholique
sans par
deux à la fois nos analyses l'état des
lieux des propositions et que en lien
avec les fidèles catholiques en
interaction avec le corps social
elles prennent les mesures qui
s'imposent jean-marc sauvé passe le
témoin à l'église mais aussi à la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
créé en janvier 2021
voilà on débat maintenant autour de la
remise de ce rapport de la commission
sauvé et puis de ses conséquences plus
générale dans dans la société française
je vous présente mes invités laurence
rossignol bonsoir bonsoir cette
sénatrice de l'oise vice-présidente du
sénat ancien ministre d famille de
l'enfance et des droits des femmes
andrea besco bonsoir autrice
réalisatrice comédienne votre pièce
suivi d'un film les chatouille ou la
danse de la colère raconte votre
histoire et à donner du courage à
beaucoup d'autres victimes de la
pédophilie je peux en témoigner pour les
avoir venir vous parler à la fin de vos
spectacles vous publiez et si on se
parlait un petit livre pour aider les
enfants à parler de tout sans tabou chez
harper collins bonsoir edouard durant
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi vous
êtes juge des enfants et coprésident de
la commission indépendante sur l'inceste
et les violences sexuelles envers les
enfants et puis avec nous en
visioconférence j'accueille également
muriel salmona qu'est psychiatre et
présidente de l'association mémoire
traumatique et victimologie bonsoir
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
laetitia cru pas est évidemment toujours
à mes côtés l'éditorialiste de sang ce
public alors il ya d'abord ces chiffres
que voilà que qu'on entend depuis ce
matin et que je voudrais rappeler est
derrière ces chiffres il ya autant de de
douleurs d'enfant brisé deux familles
qui sont fracturées deux cent seize
mille mineurs agressés par des hommes
d'église 330 mille jeunes victimes sinon
on ajoute les faits commis par des laïcs
missionné par l'institution religieuse
andrea bescond comment vous avez réagi
en entendant jean-marc sauvé ce matin en
entendant ces chiffres mais je n'ai pas
été surprise je trouve le travail
honorable travail dans la quête
honorable est très important et c'est
formidable de pouvoir chiffrer
concrètement mais on savait que ces
chiffres-là existait en fait je suis
absolument pas surprise de ça ça fait
des années qu'on sait que la
pédocriminalité est un fléau sans borne
sans frontières sans culture
son niveau social donc l'église l'église
là cette enquête elle représente aussi
le fléau sein de cette société tout
simplement est donc ce chiffre là on les
connaît depuis longtemps génèrent un
enfant sur cinq victimes de violences
sexuelles par le conseil de l'europe
c'est est étudiée il ya bien des années
le hashtag mitu inceste et le plus de
90000 témoignages sur twitter
je me souviens entendre tout ce que j'ai
entendu aujourd'hui ces chiffres
effroyables
incroyable mais il fallait croire
ça fait longtemps que ça existe et c'est
toujours là et il faut le traiter
maintenant vraiment avec des actes et ce
sera évidemment l'un des thèmes de cette
émission et de ce débat laurence
rossignol est ce que finalement
l'ampleur de ces chiffres est ce que ça
dit quelque chose de systémique vous
employer ce terme oui je crois que c'est
systémique est d'abord joie c'est un
travail qui a été fait par la commission
avait présidé par jean-marc sauvé qui
est un travail dans quête d' analyses et
des expertises absolument remarquable et
de préconisations et des couteaux 6 et
des ouïes doit tendre une enquête
enquête enquête et groupe l'on témoigne
balade écoute qu un travail remarquable
il est clair que c'est systémique parce
que c'est pas simplement une somme de
faits individuels une somme d'auteur est
victime
c'est une institution dans laquelle les
la prédation sexuelle a été tolérée on a
pas on n'a pas écouté les victimes on ne
les a pas aidés l'église ne les a pas
aidés elle ne les a pas considérer et
elle n'a rien fait pour prévenir
d'autres victimes parce que au delà du
fait de la somme des faits il y à toute
la complicité j'aurais fait un juste une
remarque en début d'émission parce que
il se trouve que l'église catholique à
la spécificité d'avoir de porter une
parole père ante ouah souvent sur les
questions de sexualité l'église
catholique a un point de vue très claire
sur ce qui est une bonne sexualité une
sexualité conforme et une mauvaise
sexualité sur ce que les deux femmes
peuvent ou ne peuvent pas faire avec
leur corps l'avortement la contraception
l'homosexualité tout ça fait partie des
messages que l'église inflige à toute
notre société et qui parfois influence
le politique également et je crois qu'à
minima à l'issue de ce travail c'est
peut-être parce que la commission
souhaitait en faire mais je bous moi de
mon point de vue je suis dans
l'obligation de dire que je considère
que l'église est disqualifié pour parler
de la sexualité des autres après ce
travail là pour aller identifier ce qui
est une sexualité dans le péché ou une
sexualité hors du péché pour infliger
aux femmes comme ça a été fait pendant
des années le non recours à l'avortement
pour nous infliger une sexuelle pour
infliger aux femmes une sexualité qui
est une sexualité de contraintes et
aujourd'hui l'église serait bien inspiré
de ne plus s'exprimer sur ce que doit
être la sexualité des femmes et des
hommes que s'agisse de l'homosexualité
ou du droit des femmes à disposer de
leur corps edouard durant vous je le
rappelle co présidé avec
la travailleuse sociale nathalie mathieu
cette commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
envers les enfants
peut-être ce qui vous rapproche de la
commission sauvé c'est quoi l écoute est
ce que c'est le terme qui ne vous
viendrait en premier
oui vous avez raison assurément ce qui
est commun à ces deux commissions et
probablement très inédit c'est le fait
qu'une instance officielle soit chargée
de recueillir la parole des personnes
qui ont été victimes de violences
sexuelles l'église de france a donné
l'exemple
elle a donné d'elle-même et à la inspiré
l'état il faut maintenant qu'elle
inspire les autres institutions parce
que je ne vois pas de raison que ce qui
se produit dans l'église ne se produise
pas dans les autres institutions
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
mais toutes les autres institutions
l'école le sport la famille les autres
religions la danse
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas l'église qu'il
faut regarder sont les enfants est-ce
qu'on attaque église où est-ce qu'on
protège les enfants c'est très important
parce que mon rôle de juge des enfants
et mon rôle de président de cette
commission indépendante est de toujours
focalisé l'attention sur la façon dont
nous envisageons notre devoir de
protection des enfants et ce chiffre de
10% de la population je suis d'accord
avec andrea bescond et avec laurence
rossignol il ne nous surprend pas il a
toujours été minimisée il a toujours été
minimisé par toutes les institutions
70% des plaintes déposées pour des
violences sexuelles sont classées sans
suite
ceci signifie que non seulement l'église
mais les enseignants les parents les
juges ne croient pas un être humain qui
dit j'ai aidé violer
c'est ceci qu'il faut changer quel que
soit l'institution à laquelle on
appartient et ce rapport qui se fonde
sur la parole des victimes que jean-marc
sauvé et son équipe a entendu comme les
personnes que nous entendons depuis que
nous sommes désignés le 23 janvier est
extrêmement fort parce que la légitimité
vient et c'est une des formes de
légitimité la plus importante de
l'expérience des personnes qui ont été
confrontées non seulement à la violence
mais à la réponse que leur a donné la
société lorsqu'elles ont appelé à l'aide
et souvent cette réponse a été
inadéquate c'est ça ce qu'il faut
changer il me semble que vous oubliez le
bout de du processus c'est à dire que
effectivement il faut écouter vous avez
raison thomas ensuite il faut prendre
les plaintes au sérieux et ne pas les
classer sans suite mais ensuite une fois
qu'on est au tribunal vous n'avez pas au
bout quand la personne est là la
personne coupable et là il ya très peu
de condamnations dans le cas notamment
princesse intrafamiliaux donc pourquoi
monsieur la justice ne
punit pas de façon ferme et définitive à
même pour symbole sociétale ces sommes
puisque en général ce sont des sommes
fautifs je suis assez d'accord avec vous
à ceci près que le carrefour stratégique
c'est le moment des poursuites ce que
nous voyons c'est que dès lors que des
poursuites sont engagées dans la plupart
des cas la condamnation suit mais vous
avez raison on a 160 mille enfants
chaque année en france victimes de
violences sexuelles 70% de classement
sans suite violences sexuelles faites
aux mineurs et aux adultes
essentiellement des femmes et à peu près
1000 condamnation par an un écart
abyssal dans la chaîne de la protection
et ce qui importe c'est de repérer
comment fonctionne cette chaîne du point
de départ au point d'aboutissement c'est
à dire le que le point de départ c'est
la façon dont un adulte est en capacité
d'inspirer confiance à un enfant pour
que l'enfant se disent à elle à lui je
peux dire parce qu'elle va me croire il
va me croire c'est une extrêmement c'est
un investissement citoyen et faut que
chaque adulte prennent conscience que
c'est un citoyen en fait de réagir pour
un enfant qui est en situation de
maltraitance ou de vulnérabilité
d'agression mais effectivement faut que
le système suivre derrière ce que vous
soulignez très important le dire par
exemple aller et quelques prêtres très
âgées certainement dans les faits
seraient prescrits ou non prescrits faim
prescrit en l'occurrence mais vont
mourir de leur belle mort sans être
inquiétés de gérer ne transpire pas ce
soir un ces messieurs la mauricie ce
coup là bon on est un petit peu on parle
de nouveau demain sera fin prêt demain
sans oublier on va pas se mentir ça va
être comme à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
grands chocs mais qui sont un choc
pendant 24 heures et puis après bompard
va faire des grenelle puis des
commissions puis des réunions et puis
les numéros verts et puis finalement
l'action st même quand monsieur comme
juste durant parle de l'enfance qu'il
faut se projeter sur l'enfance et
regarder enfance à écouter l'enfance
déjà d'abord pourquoi on a absolument
pas de prévention sans éducation
nationale que cette prévention contre
les violences sans dire que les enfants
d'être agressés je veux dire faut pas
que ce soit monsieur gêne évidemment
mais parler aux enfants de leurs droits
de ce qu'on a droit de leur fille de de
faire ou ne pas faire nommer les choses
c'est très important et pour l'instant
l'état alors vous parlez des taxes était
un exemple ce que l'église a montré
l'exemple à l'état mme me semble que
l'état ne s'empare pas du tout du du
fléau comme ils le devraient depuis des
années maintenant et des commissions
très importante et je néglige pas le
travail d'enquêté de témoignages qui est
mise en avant je n'ai que par contre je
je reproche à l'état de ne pas
accompagner ces plateformes de
témoignages de réelles mesures et
surtout concernant clairement les
enfants et pouvoir protéger les enfants
du clae laurence rossignol et d'ordures
vous avez envie de répondre et puis
jusqu'à près je n'oublie pas évidemment
que muriel salmona est avec nous et j'ai
beaucoup de questions à vous poser dans
un court instant muriel salmona lancé
oui je pense qu'il ya une culture finale
est aussi un code pénal qui sont très
défavorables à la parole des victimes de
violences sexuelles qu'il s'agisse des
femmes ou des enfants d'abord il y a
toujours une suspicion de mensonge
d'aubry il n'y a pas une résolution de
crédibilité la suspicion l'emportent sur
la présomption de crédibilité c'est à
dire qu'en fait quand une femme ou un
enfant dénonce on se demande qui
concerne la femme pourquoi elle le fait
qu'elle est son intérêt à le faire pour
cherche une raison cachée et sur
l'enfant il ya tout un discours autour
de la parole de l'enfant qui d'ailleurs
souvent est celui de la manipulation des
mères les bersonnais de manipuler et
donc la parole de l'enfant et la parole
des femmes n'ait pas cru a priori donc
ministre qu'est ce que vous n'avez pas
pu
actionner à ce moment là puisque côté il
se dit andreas est aussi un peu une
pierre j'étais milan 1-2 tout ça c'est
qu'on est ministre et ministre et j'ai
travaillé aussi bien avec édouard
durenque avec andré ans
j'étais un autre
autre moment où les populations voilà
j'ai porté ce que je pouvais penser
avant minuit avant c'était
le premier but contre énorme erreur
absolue mais n'ont pas loupé à tous un
tatouage et j'ai peur je veux pas je
vais pas faire mon bilan est mais me
dédouaner j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu à ce
moment là dans une société qui n'était
pas consciente et sensible et
sensibiliser comme elle l'est
aujourd'hui à ces sujets vous savez il
ya avant mi tout et après me tout bien
sûr depuis mis tout le mythe ou des
femmes le mythe ou de l'inceste remis
tout gai le mytho de mitu de la
pédocriminalité la parole ajayi à
l'époque quand on a commencé à
travailler ensemble j'ai envie de dire
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu pas seul grâce
à des gens comme et d'or durant avec
lequel déjà on avait travaillé sur
l'allongement des délais rescrit psion
on a parlé de la prescription edouard
durant un mot de réponse à andrea il
s'est ensuite fait je vais un peu
merci beaucoup c'est important oui je ce
que je voudrais dire très simplement
c'est que la commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants une double vocation
qui est recueillir la parole des
personnes qui ont été victimes de
violences sexuelles dans leur enfance
pour construire une politique publique
je voudrais dire un mot sur saint
recueillir la parole c'est important les
personnes nous disent que nous
rencontrons autour d'une table comme
celle ci où qui nous téléphonent ou nous
écrivent nous disent vous ne savez pas
le bien que ça me fait que ma parole
soit entendue par une instance publique
il ya une différence entre
twitter et être auditionnés par une
commission qui représente la société et
une volonté publique ça c'est une
première chose et quand on se donne pour
objectif de recueillir cette parole on
va jusqu'au bout on le fait et la
seconde chose c'est que respecter cette
parole c'est là respecté jusqu'à
construire une politique publique de
protection qui se fonde sur cette parole
mais c'est un objectif c'est l'objectif
mais cet objectif n'attendra pas deux
ans c'est ce que je veux dire
naturellement compter sur moi pour que
dès que nous aurons des préconisations à
faire et nous en aurons dans quelques
jours et notamment sur les maires
confrontés à la justice lorsqu elle
révèle des faits d'inceste parce que
c'est un fait extrêmement préoccupant
nous sommes saisis très massivement de
faits de ce genre ce qu'il m'a dit je ne
les remet en français elle me semble que
dans beaucoup de pays laly nation
parentale était quand même pratique et
même si l'attrait française maison il ya
de toute façon les mécanismes de dénis
sont présents partout où il y a quelque
chose chez l'humain qui se dit ceci ne
doit pas exister et donc qui ne veut pas
le voir et il faut c'est ma conviction
que je tire de 20 ans d'audience de juge
des enfants il faut que la loi le disent
il faut que la loi soit plus impérative
pour fixer des pratiques
professionnelles qui seront réellement
protectrices muriel salmona je vous
donne la parole comme promis est-ce
qu'on peut quand même espérer que la
parole des victimes se libère de plus en
plus parce que andrea bescond disait on
a un peu le sentiment que moi à chaque
fois on se on emploie les mêmes termes
électrochoc vertigineux puis que rien ne
vaut rien ne change et ce que vous avez
le sentiment que chaque affaire chaque
scandale chaque commission permet à la
parole de se libérer alors moi je
voudrais vraiment
dire à quel point les victimes parlent
depuis longtemps avec un courage
incroyable qu'elles sont montés au
créneau que si il y à toutes ces
commissions que ce soit la commission
sauvé que ce soit là donc que ce soit la
civis c'est bien grâce aux victimes
c'est grâce à toute la mobilisation il
kim c'est elles qui font le boulot quoi
en quelque sorte donc elle parle après
celle écoute c'est vraiment qu'est ce
qu'on sait de cette parole comment la
légitime comment la reçoit et puis
comment on va la chercher aussi parce
qu'il ya les femmes qui parlent qui
souvent ont le pouvoir de parler ont la
possibilité de parler qui parle pour les
autres et qui sont soutenues et puis il
ya toutes les toutes les victimes qui ne
peuvent pas parler parce que elles sont
trop précarisés trop vulnérable parce
que l son handicap est en situation de
handicap lourd et celle là c'est celle
justement kir qui subissent le plus de
victimes de plus de violence et donc
faut se dire que tous les chiffres sont
minimisés parce que les victimes les
personnes qui subissent le plus de
violence c'est celle qui sont jamais
entendus en quelque 100 tout jamais
recherché par les enquêtes ben ça il
faut vraiment changer la donne pour
aller vers ces personnes et les protéger
et puis et puis il est il est absolument
essentiel
effectivement que la justice suive que
l'impunité
soit combattue et que surtout l'état
fasse un peu comme l'église donc les
baisses bien obligé de le faire
reconnaître ses responsabilités
reconnaissent ces défaillances
reconnaisse qu'elle n'a pas rempli ses
obligations pour prévenir ces violences
qui sont des crimes ont comme le dit la
cour européenne des des crimes graves
dégradants et inhumains cruels et c'est
même de plus en plus considérés comme
des tortures au niveau international et
qu' il ya une obligation poursuivre
c'est une obligation de protéger les
victimes de poursuivre les agresseurs et
de les condamner qui est que là il ya
une faillite totale là se dressent
vraiment qui est que les pouvoirs
publics vraiment mettre en place des
mesures énorme pour pour changer cette
situation on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
continuer à vue dans une société il ya
autant de violence etc sont mes salmona
je propose d'écouter le témoignage de
l'une des trois cent trente mille
victimes recensées par la lassiaz la
commission sauvé elle s'appelle marie
claire sylvestre elle a été abusée
sexuellement par un prêtre qui était
aussi son oncle et elle a gardé ce
secret enfoui jusqu'en 2008 on écoute
moi j'aurais bien aimé recevoir pour
peut-être pas un coup de fil mais moi un
petit mail madame voilà jamais rien
personne n'est venu vers moi et pourtant
je me suis manifester ça je trouve ça
je ne mets pas ça ne m'est pas parce que
la reconnaissance alliés pas elle est
globale faudrait une reconnaissance
individuelle ah oui ça prend beaucoup de
temps mais je sais pas mais c'est quand
même aux évêques et aux clercs à se
manifester c'est quand même mais sont
quand même représentant de l'institution
salmona 7 cette absence de
de reconnaissance a évidemment son 17è
systémique donc il ya une logique mais
que peuvent faire justement les prêtres
ou l'institution religieuse aujourd'hui
on va commencer à parler de la
réparation dans ce débat qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous de votre de votre
regard de psychologues de psychiatres
lorsque j'en pense c'est que la
reconnaissance et est très importante
c'est clair mais elle est loin de
suffire sans qu'elle soit réelle cette
reconnaissance authentique qu'elle
prenne en compte la réalité de ce qu'a
subi de ce qu'ont subies les victimes
mais elle doit s'accompagner absolument
d'un respect des droits des victimes à
être prise en charge à être aidé et
soutenu à être ont réparé la prise en
charge sociale est aussi extrêmement
important que la prise en charge en
termes de santé est essentielle ces
violences ont des conséquences
psychotraumatiques extrêmement lourdes à
long terme et représente une perte de
chance énorme en terme de santé mentale
et physique avec vraiment des risques de
suicides de dépressions de conduites
addictives de troubles anxieux très très
lourd et de ton bouquin de musculaire en
casamance c'est s'aider des conséquences
a laissé des vies dévastées
d'ailleurs il faut pas oublier jean marc
sauvé en a parlé donc toutes les
victimes qui ne sont plus là qui se
maquille c'est avoir subi des violences
par sciemment des violences sexuelles
dans l'enfance est la première cause de
suicide c'est ça il ya un risque de 20
ans d'espérance de vie en moins donc la
perte de chance et est énorme donc la
reconnaissance oui mais il faut
absolument agir pour respecter les
droits des personnes et vise à éviter
c'est éviter cette table de chance et
puis surtout éviter la réitération fin
gère les victimes quand elle parle elle
parle parce qu'elles veulent la justice
elles veulent être reconnus mais elle
que les autres victimes ne subissent pas
ce qu'elles ont subi mais pas cette vie
fracassée et donc l bac pour les autres
elles prennent leur courage à deux mains
pour se battre pour toutes les autres
victimes il faut en oublier aucune
les affaires de rester avec nous mais
rien salmona entendrait
parler pour les autres victimes c'est
aussi c'est aussi votre démarche
c'est vrai que quand
j'avais porté plainte il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont déroulés dans un ordre
très différents mais j'avais porté
plainte effectivement pour protéger les
petites filles de la personne qui
m'avait violée quand j'étais enfant et
quantum est vraiment revenu parce que
j'étais h avesnes à une amnésie
traumatique jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que je
commence un peu les relations sexuelles
tout m'est revenu en fait donc la
musique traumatique dont on parlerait à
muriel beaucoup mieux que moi mais quels
cas pour quatre victimes sur 10 quand
même donc évidemment on oublie tout et
puis ça peut revenir mais enfin bref
quand j'ai porté plainte s'est passé
petite fille ensuite quand j'ai écrit je
les fais pour moi parce que je n'allais
pas mieux se taire que j'ai été en cour
d'assises l'agresseur était condamné
j'ai une réponse moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir la réponse de la justice cet
homme là est parti en prison et puis en
fait je suis ressorti que l'indicé
nikkei j'avais toujours aussi mal acquis
tout ça pour quoi je ne connaissais pas
tout le travail de salmona d'autres
associations et d'autres travaux mais
donc j'avais besoin de me pencher je me
suis rendu compte qu'effectivement la
résilience tout ça c'est une histoire
d'étape mais c'est une une accumulation
d'étape ça ne suffit pas que de parler
ça ne suffit pas que d'avoir une réponse
de justice ça ne suffit pas que d'avoir
été entendus tout toutes ses global en
fait c'est une remontée globale de la
réparation est effectivement après
l'écriture du spectacle je l'avais fait
un peu pour moi et parce que j'en avais
besoin et je me suis rendu compte que je
n'avais jamais touché du doigt ce fléau
et je ne savais pas vraiment pas à quoi
je touchais camp en 2012 j'ai écrit ça
et je pensais de la seule au monde en
fait fait chez moi suis rendu compte
qu'on était à peu près un enfant sur
cinq sont le conseil de l'europe avoir
subi des agressions sexuelles donc dans
dans notre enfance donc effectivement
parle pour lui aussi pour protéger les
autres parce que c'est vraiment
extrêmement importante puisqu'on sait
comme souligné muriel on est passé tout
est tous passés même système
d'autodestruction de l'addiction de
conduite suicidaire conduites à risques
de voyager manger je suis passé par la
drogue l'alcool je veux vraiment tout ça
en très peu de temps donc vraiment on
peut tout et tous témoigné de st
il ya un endroit quand je vous dis on
perd quelque chose on le perd vraiment
et ce pour toujours maintenant on peut
se reconstruire mais on a perdu quelque
chose il faut parler pour les autres oui
mais il faut il faut il faut fouetter
injonction si on a voilà on fait comme
on peut aussi avec ce qu'on a ce qu'on
nous a infligées
ensuite je crois et c'est mais c'est
tout à fait personnel je crois qu'il est
important de porter plainte même si
malheureusement pour l'instant il n'y a
pas la réponse pénale qu'on dont on
aurait besoin dans les victimes
enfin pour les victimes devraient
recevoir mes portraits pleins de même
pour chiffrer on le voit là aujourd'hui
c'est important de chiffres et on a
peut-être besoin de chiffres est
constamment maintenant j'espère monsieur
durand que vous dites vrai que des
préconisations pour les enfants vont
être très très très très vite adoptée
pour pour cette élection c'est parfait
je ne doute pas de vous je suis du
système français parce que la révolte
hashtag mitu inceste a été vraiment tuer
dans l'oeuf est clos a billion kyi qui
n'a pas répondu à l'exigence du fléau
donc voilà j'ai perdu confiance moi en
l'état français par rapport à ce fléau
de la pédocriminalité et de l'inceste
donc j'attends impatiemment des actes
oui on parle pour les autres justement
nous sommes des dizaines des centaines
des milliers d midi mais bien des
millions de victimes a raconté ce qu'on
a subi à le faire porter à nos familles
le faire porter à nos entourages
c'est quelque chose de très fort de
faire ça dans la vie pour l'instant la
france ne s'empare pas du fléau comme
elle le devrait alors que le hashtag
mythe ou 1,16 par exemple c'est quelque
chose d'assez sans précédent ça n'est
arrivé nulle part ailleurs et chiffré
des victimes et entendre des victimes ça
date pas d'hier même si évidemment c'est
important de les analyser de tout
répertorier et de préconiser des choses
à la suite de cette étude met vraiment
là on s'est quand même ce qu'on peut
mettre tout de suite en action
aujourd'hui pour protéger les enfants
pourquoi attendre dans ce que vous dites
ya cette inertie politique en parler
avec quentin calmer tout le monde quand
un bon soir
soixante rang sur les travaux qui ont
été menés au sénat sur ces violences
sexuelles oui sur mineurs c'est vrai que
c'est un débat qui est monté aussi avec
l'opinion à vous disiez les hashtag et
on a vu aussi ce débat monte au sénat il
ya une pétition qui a été a publié en
octobre c'est un tas 2018 une pétition
du de l'hebdomadaire témoignage chrétien
qui demande la création d'une mission
parlementaire d'une commission denquête
une demande relayée à ce moment là par
les sénateurs socialistes qui proposent
une telle commission au sénat sauf que
la droite ici refuse en avançant un
argument technique les commissions
parlementaires ne peuvent pas enquêter
sur les affaires judiciaires en cours
écoutez la sénatrice et l'air catherine
de roche
comme ils sont en quête ç'avait été
clairement dit par le président bah
l'époque ce n'était pas possible dans la
mesure où elles procès barbarin qui est
en cours qui portait sur le même sujet
contrairement à faire benalla donc on ne
pouvait pas faire de commission denquête
son n'aura pas été recevable en revanche
on avait on avait dit on ne fera pas que
l'église mais on fera l'église mais pas
que l'église mais l'argument avait jugé
un peu court a notamment par la gauche
car il est vrai qu'il est arrivé un
conte enquête au sénat sur des sujets où
il ya des enquêtes judiciaires comme
appât un peu l'usiné lubrizol où la
sphère benalla bien sûr mais le sujet de
l'église en fait c'est très sensible un
pur à la majorité de la droite et du
centre ici les sénateurs à va être donc
étendu leur travail à toutes les
institutions qui reçoivent des enfants
avec à la clé des dizaines de
recommandations mais on en a retenu deux
qui étaient saillantes à l'époque il
voulait un sénateur que l'on contrôle
davantage les personnes qui encadrent
ces enfants y jouent également
l'amélioration de la formation des
professionnels qui pourrait recueillir
la parole et des victimes dax d'actes
sexuels des mesures qui pour certaines
ne sont toujours pas appliquées nous a
dit l'une des co rapporteur dominique
j'ai rien on se rend compte que il y à
un système pour les colonies de vacances
automatique qui est très simple et
étonnamment on ne saurait pas mettre ce
système en place pour les clubs de sport
pour les écoles pour l'école et les
communes je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça
ne dépend pas de la loi à mon avis c'est
plus du réglementaire il faut se bouger
mais plus on sera conscient du danger et
plus on saura mettre les moyens pour
lutter conte voilà les sénateurs qui
vont pouvoir se pencher à nouveau sur ce
sujet puisque un projet de loi porté par
des attaques et arrive au sénat bientôt
au mois d'octobre merci à vous merci
quant à calmer laetitia crois pas je me
tourne bien vous parce que s'il ya
défaillance ou inertie politique c'est
souvent du côté de la société civile
mais aussi des artistes on en parlait
avec andrea du cinéma qu'il faut se
tourner mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que oui voilà c'est ça que c'est
que le cinéma a révélé s'est emparé de
deux scandales de pédophilie notamment
ça a commencé aux états unis en 2015 et
sont quand même attendu 13 ans entre les
révélations du boston globe sûr c'est
toutes ces affaires de prêtres
pédophiles et spotlight sort en 2015 et
primé ensuite à deux oscars l'année
suivante mais on redécouvre en 2018 que
à nouveau des scandales de pédophilie
éclabousse 300 prêtres en pennsylvanie
est donc finalement le clergé n'a pas
fait le travail en a pas fait le ménage
en france qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'était beaucoup plus rapprochées dans
le temps et c'était même concomitants
c'est à dire qu'il ya le film de
françois ozon grâce à dieu qui s'empare
de la sphère du père prenne a dit
affaires barbarin par la suite et alors
ils ont les lisent a tout fait pour
empêcher la sortie de gym parce que au
motif qu effectivement la sphère était
en cours le film est tout de même sortie
a été primé à berlin
et quand il a reçu son prix françois
ozon a dit je veux partager ce prix avec
les hommes libres qui m'ont inspiré en
citant toutes les victimes du père
prenne à et bien sûr que le cinéma
s'empare de ces sujets et fait pression
avec la société civile sur les
politiques et notamment sur l'église
parce qu'il me semble que parce que la
pression était très forte l'église a
décidé monsieur vous disiez l'église
donne l'exemple à l'état mais c'est
parce que l'opinion publique a su
pression sur l'église depuis la lettre
du pape est donc l'église très bien
s'est senti un peu obligé effectivement
de faire un mea culpa
merci laëtitia il nous reste moins de
dix minutes et je voudrais qu'on
consacre du temps la question de la
prescription et sur
cet aspect du débat on va écouter pour
le lancer ce chapitre le ministre de la
justice eric dupond moretti c'était en
janvier dernier il est temps en séance
au sénat
son visage ou l'imprescriptibilité des
crimes qui nous
qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui faudra
qu'on envisage l'imprescriptibilité
d'autres crimes pourquoi pas
l'imprescriptibilité des meurtres des
assassinats ou il ya aussi des victimes
de vraies victimes bien sûr comme dans
toutes ces infractions
absolument atroce il ya aussi la
question du dépérissement de la preuve
bien évidemment certains nombre d'eux un
certain nombre de très hauts magistrats
de ce pays se sont exprimés sur cette
question sont défavorables à
l'imprescriptibilité il ya aussi l'idée
même de ce qu'est la prescription il a
fallu des millénaires pour que notre
société civilisée envisage ce qu'est la
prescription elle a aussi un certain
nombre d'avantagés sociaux sociétaux
qu'on ne peut pas sous le coup de
l'émotion balayé d'un revers de manche
ont demandé ces crimes pédophiles
devienne un prisme risible
j'écoutais le garde des sceaux est bon
après ce monsieur adam dirait semblait
que qu'une tante de 18 ans pourraient
sortir et que son neveu de 16 sans que
ça pose aucun problème lorsque quelqu'un
qui a une drôle de façon de penser
faucheux tient jamais trop de enfin je
sais pas je ne comprends pas cet homme
donc après son à prescription en effet
je pense qu'on est dans un état de droit
et non de justice majoritairement et moi
j'ai évidemment je suis pour
l'imprescriptibilité bon moi je t'ai
victimes de violences en france
seulement en plus on a ce regard là mais
mais pour déjà l'amnésie traumatique
dont je vous parlais qu'est reconnue
scientifiquement et beaucoup de victimes
sont aussi doublement victime du coup de
cet oubli puis de ce retour de souvenirs
ont parfois malheureusement on n'a plus
le temps de porter plainte maintenant
c'est pour un problème d'impunité aussi
sait combien de temps ces trente ans
après la majorité mais il faut avoir
moins de 38 en 2018 parce que vous savez
c'est pas rétroactif les lois donc la
loi chez à part nous le disent et en
2018 a offert cette perspective un ca de
ce rallongement des délais mais voilà
deux mois ce qui ce qui ce qui me
chagrine beaucoup c'est évidemment les
coûts des victimes une réponse pénale
une réponse de justice mais aussi
l'impunité des agresseurs et de voir à
quel point la société des adultes se
serre les coudes pour être sûr de ne pas
faire trop de vagues et malheureusement
cette prescription elle offre une totale
impunité et d'ailleurs on évoquait les
les prêtres tout à l'heure certainement
très âgés mais qui vont aller
tranquillement vivre leur belle mort
sans être inquiété par qui que ce soit
en ayant violé des enfants oui puisque
la commission sauvé c'était de 1950 à
2000 20h et suites judiciaires muriel
salmona pourquoi selon vous il faut
rendre ces crimes pédophiles
imprescriptible c'est quoi ce ce
cheminement traumatique d'en parler à
l'âge alors déjà je voudrais rappeler
que là tu le conseil de l'europe
recommande à tous des pays européens
de mettre en place une imprescriptible
it et donc et que devant décider des
crimes aussi graves avec des
conséquences aussi longue et aussi
destructrice et avec un caractère
systémique ont comme on l'a vu jeudi ses
des crimes qui en ont vraiment une
spécificité et en plus il ya
effectivement ces crimes en entraîne de
tels troubles psychotraumatiques c'est
quand même des crimes son plein le plus
de troubles psychotraumatiques et le
cerveau met en place une stratégie de
survie en fait qui déconnecte les
émotions et déconne être le circuit delà
de la mémoire et c'est pour ça qu'on se
retrouve avec des amnésies traumatique
dissociatifs qui peuvent durer 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans 40 ans et dans le rapport de
la sias on ne voit bien à quel point
c'est c'est omniprésent mais tous les
souvenirs reviennent à un moment donné
et les genres vivent à l'identique avec
la mort traumatique la torture de ces
violences dernière chose qui est
vraiment très importante c'est que les
agresseurs souvent sont de très
nombreuses victimes et ils font des
carrières de prédateurs et donc c'est
aussi la prescription militer c'est
aussi une façon très efficace
de lutter contre l'impunité et de
prévenir de nouvelles violences et
fauchon pas oublier cette réalité là et
da est encore une toute petite chose là
dépérissement des preuves c'est quand
même assez fou d'entendre cet argument
là alors que c'est quasiment ce concert
aux victimes si elles viennent 72 heures
après le violent ou une semaine après ou
un mois après où un an après 74 %
classement sans suite après dvd c'est
criminel donc on est tout le temps en
train de renvoyer aux victimes qui a pas
suffisamment de preuves alors que on
pourrait tout à fait ce travail que je
suis avec lui le prix nobel de la paix
le dr denis de vaux way qui est qui et
qui n'étant d'europe en ce moment et
pour vraiment faire en sorte que
l'analyse médico-légale des troubles
psychotraumatiques soit reconnue échos
aussi on a aussi la possibilité je
voudrais pardon je vous interromps suis
vraiment désolé de le faire mais un
salmona mais je voudrais il nous reste
moins de moins de 3000 s'entendre sur
cette question de la prescription à la
fois edouard durand et lance au signal
la question judiciaire effectivement le
dépérissement des preuves est ce que
c'est un argument recevable
je ne crois pas en tout cas je ne je ne
le retiendrait pas pour ma part ce qui
compte c'est en effet dès les premières
révélations de violence que les premiers
actes d' enquêtes permettent de
recueillir toutes les preuves possibles
et que au cours de l' enquête il soit
envisagé de recueillir toutes les
preuves possibles qui peuvent être des
preuves matérielles mais qui sont aussi
des preuves dans l'ordre du traumatisme
épreuve de l'ordre de l'audition de
l'enfant victime ou de la personne
victime adultes et de l'audition de
l'entourage proche puisque en effet il
peut y avoir plusieurs victimes et on
voit que avec la formation des gendarmes
par exemple la commission était à
rosny-sous-bois aujourd'hui au fort de
la gendarmerie via un programme de
formation sur l'audition des enfants
victimes on peut progresser
considérablement et donc
recueillir des preuves ensuite il y à un
point qui est très important pour moi
que l'on dise pour de bonnes raisons il
ne peut pas avoir l'impression petit
billy t on peut en discuter mais pas
pour de mauvaises raisons
parce qu'on dit souvent la prescription
a été conçu pour garantir la paix
sociale en réalité ce qui a été conçu
pour garantir la paix sociale c'est de
rendre la justice
et saas est absolument essentiel si
beaucoup laurence rossignol ce même
thème pour conclure mais écoutez moi
j'ai lancé fin 2016 début 2010 est la
première mission sur la question de la
prescription est justement en raison des
crimes sexuels commis sur les mineurs je
pense qu'on viendra à
l'imprescriptibilité
c'est inéluctable maintenant on a
rallongé d'un allongé de 10 en deux ans
après voilà deux ans après la mission
que j'avais lancé la prescription était
allongé de 10 ans et c'est un un combat
que porte des associations les
personnalités engagées on y viendra en
même temps dernier mot en même temps
j'espère moi que on jugera les auteurs
avant que la victime et 48 ans ou avant
qu'elle ait 58 ans parce que ce que
révèle aussi notre débat sur la
prescription c'est notre fragilité à
juger en temps des victimes les
poursuivre les auteurs et les condamner
merci vivent des auteurs et pendant
qu'elle victimes peuvent encore être
réparé merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci à muriel salmona
évidemment